so as the Joe and Hunter Biden
scandaloper deepens and widens what
should we make of these new allegations
joining us now to answer those questions
and more Foxy's contributor and George
Washington University law professor
Jonathan Turley
Professor trilli welcome to the show I
feel like there was a lot of news around
Hunter bite in particular this week and
of course this is a hunter Biden and Joe
Biden as I call it scandalabra but walk
us through what really struck you what
you should be looking for
well you know this is a city that floats
on leaks there's lots of things that
come over the transom so you often have
to make a sort of gut check on how much
credibility and weight to give something
on that scale the types of of stories I
give the most weight to are the ones
from whistleblowers directly to Congress
the reason is that those are individuals
who know that they can beat criminally
charged for lying to investigators so
this isn't just something coming over
the transom to The Washington Post it's
not some anonymous source that a
reporter is citing it is someone who has
met with investigators and is subject to
that penalty so you have to take it
seriously and there is a sharp
disconnect right when we had a
whistleblower in the first Trump
impeachment the media really went you
know full board into this uh this story
they're showing a lot more skepticism
here but we have to just learn the
details but one of the reasons kellyanne
that this is so serious is because of
what we know already you know the Biden
family has been known for influence
peddling for years now influence
pedaling is one of the sort of cottage
industries of Washington as you know but
the bidens really set a new standard uh
in terms of how much money is being
traced to family members
well there's no question about that and
I think chairman Comer is doing a
fabulous job and at least keeping us all
up to speed on what he can without
divulging confidence is it really struck
me Professor trilli that Hunter Biden
hired a new lawyer Abby Lowell and
apparently this is what ruffled a lot of
feathers at the White House Abby Lovell
is known as more aggressive maybe than
the lawyers that Bob Bauer at the White
House and others had put together for
Hunter Biden I think Kevin quirk's
reporting the access report makes very
clear clashes going rogue they're upset
look this white house needs to reelect
an unpopular president and an unpopular
vice president they don't need Hunter
Biden's scandals in the way but tell us
what you think of the hiring of Abby
Lowell and and how that affects this
moving forward
well I know Abby what was interesting
and you were the most sophisticated
political figures in the city so it'd be
interesting get your take on this but I
I was surprised when the post first
reported a meeting of a new team for
Hunter Biden that includes people that
have been supporting him financially and
the whole thrust of the the story was
that they were going to go with a
scorched Earth campaign that they were
going to go aggressive and what was
weird about that is it had to come from
those individuals this was a leak from a
relatively small number of people they
wanted witnesses to know that they were
going to go after Witnesses and Abby
Lowell issued a letter saying that the
IRS should investigate some of the
critics of Hunter Biden that there
should be criminal investigations with
potential Witnesses that's getting
uncomfortably close to the line if those
lawyers then reach out to Witnesses with
that type of heavy message you could
really sort of trip some wires
particularly with a congressional
investigation now in the field
Professor Charlie let's shift gears just
a little bit and go back to this I think
bombshell revelation in these emails
that you had two former CIA Chiefs
colluding to provide Joe Biden with a
talking point for a presidential debate
the last debate in Nashville late
October 2020 that famous line from Joe
Biden where he says talking about Hunter
Biden's laptop is quote garbage and he
quotes that 50 Intel officials have said
it has the markings a Russian
disinformation we know that that's all
wrong now it was all a lie but it really
struck me that I saw speaking of
congressional investigations both John
Brennan and another are going to have to
go and testify in front of Congress
James Clapper going to have to go and
testify in front of Congress about the
weaponization of the government
um can you clue us into that a little
bit I I think people felt it was unfair
but now it actually has some legs
well it does I mean it does there's a
curious thing about this letter right
because we do know it's false it's soon
after this allegation came out the
American intelligence came out with a
statement that there's no evidence that
there was Russian disinformation or or
intelligence efforts here but you had
these 51 experts that wanted to get this
out right before the campaign and now
we're learning pretty much what was
presumed that this was an effort of the
Biden campaign uh to give him this
talking point and earlier as you know
morale basically said that the trigger
for this was now Secretary of State
blinken and that he gave him this
initial disinformation line and yet
everyone involved says they did nothing
wrong not the organizer morale not the
trigger blinking not the signatories not
the media that ran with it no one's
taking responsibility for what was just
a really believable political yes sort
of trick and it sort of made the public
look like Chumps because it happened
right before the election and it could
have made a difference well Professor
Charlie polling showed that 17 in six or
seven key swing States said that they
would have changed their vote away from
Biden if they thought that this laptop
as contents were actually real these
folks hid behind intelligence and
National Security to make a political
point in fact to provide a quote talking
point in a debate that email makes clear
I think that's incredibly important I
want to thank you so much for walking us
through two or three very uh thorny
issues this week that came to a head in
Washington DC Professor trilli thank you